brigado com ela
é uma honra está compartilhando com
vocês meus quinze minutos de fama para
poder falar sobre metrópole porque eu
digo que é uma honra falar sobre
metrópole porque metrópole
na verdade ela implica necessariamente
uma reflexão sobre a sua história mas
principalmente sobre o futuro da
humanidade
a metrópole não é uma coisa diz trata
que está no espaço apenas como um
contexto físico é a representação de uma
série de outras circunstâncias de uma
série de outras contingências que
começam numa célula mater que a própria
cidade
a metrópole é uma no fundo é uma grande
cidade envolvida por outras cidades
menores que gravitam no seu entorno
esse conjunto faz com que essa cidade
tem as suas características sociais
culturais e políticas completamente
diferentes uma das outras
mas quando a gente está falando em
metrópole antigamente falar necessidade
depois passou a falar em metrópole e
certamente daqui uns anos só se vai
falar em megalópoles megalópole é quando
um conjunto de metrópolis se unem e
constitui um tecido urbano único e que
cujas características podem promover
toda uma diferença num contexto social e
urbana e político de uma determinada
região
nesse aspecto é interessante notar que
há uma preocupação nítida com o que vai
acontecer em termos da humanidade já que
eu falei de metrópole falei de
humanidade
daqui pro futuro o mundo hoje tem 7,2
bilhões de pessoas é estimado para 2050
tais 6 50% de aumento dessa população
estimado chegar de 2050 com 10 milhões
de pessoas
essas dez milhões de pessoas certamente
estarão concentradas há onde estou ver
mais oferta de tudo aquilo que marca a
sociedade contemporânea portanto serão
nas cidades serão nas metrópoles serão
nas megalópoles e como essas pessoas
irão viver nessas localidades
isso é que importa se a gente ficar
achando pensando como os arquitectos
durante uma época que tinha aquela
prepotência de achar que não resolverá
cidade em maquetes e projetos como se
fosse aquela ditadura do pensamento
acabou eu acho que a cidade é construída
não só por aqueles que pensa a cidade
pelos profissionais da cidade mas
principalmente pelas pessoas que vivem
na cidade
se vocês tiverem quiserem ter uma idéia
só do que é isso
percebam como é diferente até no
noticiário de televisão a conformação
dessa cidade
vamos falar um pouco de da cidade
propriamente dia as cidades como eu
coloquei aqui são símbolo da resistência
humana que são estratificados ao longo
da história
não existe uma cidade mesmo se você é
uma cidade nova brasília uma cidade
feita recentemente recentemente eu digo
50 anos é uma cidade nova
portanto uma brasília não é só aqui não
é só o plano piloto brasília é um
conjunto de fatores que forma alimenta
cidade
se nas cidades antigas e tinham a cidade
fell down ela também tinha suas regras
tinha suas maneiras de subsistência que
apresenta nessa imagem que o pradense
ano
ao mesmo tempo outras características
que seriam características culturais
econômicas físico territoriais levar as
cidades se constituir de uma maneira
diferenciada e aí é um exemplo de uma
cidade é medieval que busca uma cidade
fantástica que já tem uma outra
estrutura de composição da do seu tecido
urbano assim eles foram indo até o
momento mais adiante em que você começa
a cidade começa a se configurar de
formas diferenciadas
se vocês olharem nessas imagens em cima
vocês vão perceber que tanto você pode
ter dentro de uma cidade uma visão macro
como vocês podem ter uma visão micro
se vocês olharem a cidade no seu sentido
macro algumas têm uma expressividade
maior sobre aspectos culturais aspectos
do desenho urbano enfim de seu traçado e
da sua representatividade
nessas imagens não coloca assim vocês
vêm ao centro da cidade de paris
o seu marco principal que a torre eiffel
eo e logo abaixo a cidade do rio de
janeiro com o corcovado dominando essa
paisagem em cima já é uma outra
característica de cidade que é uma praça
principal de marrakesh marrocos ao mesmo
tempo vocês podem ver que entre o rio
entre paris e entre marrakesh são agora
são recentes não são coisas antigas como
aquelas que eu mostrei anteriormente
há uma diversidade de culturas há uma
diversidade de informações próprias da
sua natureza dessa população
e você encontra que ao lado
direita num detalhe e é espantoso essa
imagem porque ela mostra nas suas
particularidades inúmeras formas de
ocupação desses espaços que é a forma
como a sociedade ocupa essa nova délhi e
que você vê a população na rua os
diferentes formas arquitetônicas todas
elas convivendo e por último aqui
embaixo do do letreiro do texto aparece
a cidade de dubai que é uma cidade
fabricada é uma cidade que representa
muito mais a coisa virtual ela
representa o capital financeiro
internacional e que quando você olha
essas tramas comparado com nova délhi eu
pergunto onde é que anda as pessoas que
cidade é essa que as pessoas não andam
na rua onde é que está a sociedade onde
é que está o convívio social idade é um
espaço de convivência é o espaço de
interação estão fazendo na qat fazer
isso fazer aquilo pode atender os o dou
um objetivo imediato mas não sei se
serão cidade que certamente vão vingar
para o futuro mas o mais importante
quando a gente pense cidade que a cidade
referencial que nós temos no dia de hoje
é realmente a partir da sociedade
industrial a partir da revolução
industrial e das cidades que começará a
receber a grande migração que vinha do
campo duas
isso eu já estou me referindo mais
próximo seria século segunda metade do
século 19 principalmente quando as
grandes transformações urbanas tomaram
conta da cidade
então nesse aspecto que se torna
extremamente importante que eu considero
a cidade para a dig marca do século 19
que é paris e também eu poderia incluir
nesse sentido londres também paris e
londres são duas cidades marcantes de e
essas cidades começaram
conviver com essa migração de pessoas do
campo e criando situações completamente
diferente do que se imaginava até então
nesse momento surge também junto novos
paradigmas que não eram só paradigmas
urbanos mas paradigmas sociais
paradigmas culturais
essa esse conjunto de fatores passou a
se chamar na modernidade do século 19
que vai se estender para o século 20 com
o desenvolvimento da sociedade
industrial e com a produção a forma de
produção industrial e pra isso
os conceitos todos que vinham até então
começa a ser superar karl marx tem essa
frase no final de uma citação de que a
extraordinária quando ele diz e moderno
é fazer parte de um universo onde tudo
que é sólido desmancha no ar tudo quer
só no sentido de ser consistente aquilo
que você imaginar aquele eterno aquilo
que você imaginava que iria durar
aquele conceito você imaginava que seria
a solução de tudo neste período a
modernidade
ele é colocado por terra e essa
expressão a meu ver era genial quando
ele diz que tudo que é sólido desmancha
no ar o século 21
ele vem dar uma continuidade que não
existe dizer senhora terminou aqui a
ponto final acabou século 20 começou o
século 21 século 21 começou um pouco
antes de terminar o século 20 mães
ele traz consigo novos paradigmas
principalmente a tecnologias digitais
a velocidade de informação e o capital
financeiro internacional essas três
esses três fatores no meu modo de ver
modificaram toda a cultura da sociedade
contemporânea que hoje por sua vez é uma
sociedade globalizada nisso
a utopia certo
sonhos se vivia no século 20 foram
colocados por terra a visão da sociedade
como um todo passou a ser desconfiada
criou se então o chamado o aqui e agora
essa cultura está se vivendo hoje em que
viver o presente como se não houvesse
futuro e muito menos o passado tem sido
um dos caminhos a meu ver para muitas
das graças que nós estamos assistindo
diariamente nos meios de comunicação
essa visão imediatista da sociedade que
só pensa no aqui e agora que ignora o
até um indivíduo ter sentado do seu lado
é responsável por bares que estão
acontecendo no mundo contemporâneo e
está ao mesmo tempo não só criando esses
radicalismos de um lado mas também uma
ortodoxia religiosa por outro que só vêm
comprometer o que eu acho que seria mais
importante como fruto da cidade que a
confraternização das populações
principalmente no mundo globalizado e
nisso eu não acredito
quando se diz o indivíduo está no centro
do universo
eu diria pô não existe essa história de
super homem chegou a hora de nós sermos
solidários dirante de tudo que vai
acontecer daqui pra frente vamos falar
do nosso rio nosso rio que tanto fala de
metrópole não posso deixar passar o
nosso rio o rio à cidade muito especial
eu sou um carioca da gema apaixonado
pelo rio considera o rio é a cidade mais
bonita do mundo é uma cidade incrível de
um show
obrigado
ela deu um show agora nessa copa do
mundo quando ninguém esperava a
confraternização nas ruas alegria apesar
de todos e todas as coisas que nós
criticamos acabou sul é essa superação
do carioca é um negócio extraordinário
então eu acho que o rio ser carioca ter
essa diferença é fantástico
eu poderia até dizer olhando essa imagem
que deus e diabo com vivem perfeitamente
nessa terra do sol
outra expressão legal da fernandinha
abreu que é cidade maravilha purgatório
da beleza do local e do caos
essa é a diferença do rio o rio foi
capital do império foi capital da
república e teve grandes transformações
urbanas nós estamos numa aqui no teatro
municipal da formatação da república no
início do século 20
enfim até perder em 1950 a 1960 perder o
direito de ser capital federal foi
transferido para brasília mas em
compensação grandes transformações
urbanas foram feitas naquela ocasião com
uma graninha que sobrou pra compensar o
fato do brasil do rio ter perdido o
status de capital federal
isso fez por exemplo a gente tem o
aterro do flamengo depois na década de
70 o alargamento da avenida atlântica
o emissário submarino uma série de obras
extraordinárias que de repente de um
momento pra cá eu acredito que em 1980 o
julio bueno até comentou isso que é um
debate equipe financeiro no rio
o rio perdeu muito e só vai recuperar os
mais recentemente ali houve foi uma
questão política que foi uma sorte um
achado
eu nunca vi na história do rio de
janeiro ninguém vai me apontar no rio de
janeiro o governo federal estadual e
municipal se unirem
sem ser oposição isso foi um olha um
achado um milagre e o rio realmente
desfrutou dessa possibilidade
obviamente que a chamada para o rio
grande sa pelo estavam rodando em torno
das conquistas seja da copa do mundo que
o brasil mas sim a sede no rio e
principalmente em se tornar a cidade
olímpica de 2016
então o que a gente espera disso espera
e volta pouco tempo
espera-se na verdade que esses eventos
tragam o legado que seja um legado
extremamente importante do rio e que
legado é isso
não adianta não vai haver tempo de falar
em todo o legado mas eu diria dois que
eu acho perverso
isso não está acontecendo um fundamental
é a despoluição da baía de guanabara
já a lei só o que ele vai falar disso a
baía de guanabara é o grande catalisador
da região metropolitana do rio de
janeiro é inadmissível acontecer o que
está acontecendo a baía de guanabara ela
reflete o desprezo que existe por certas
camadas sociais que não têm esgoto não
tem água não tem nenhum recurso na
o outro é a despoluição das lagoas da
barra chuck é criminoso é criminoso
abordar e expandir já acha errado
expandir a cidade desnecessariamente
para a barra da tijuca com recursos
financeiros do governo
isso tinha que ser com recursos da
iniciativa privada
o governo tem que investir nos lugares
mais forte agora o principal legado que
mais me entusiasmou e que eu participei
dele eu sinceramente não decepcionar
chama se morar carioca a urbanização das
favelas do rio de janeiro
ou você urbanizar favelas do rio de
janeiro ou não se iludam porque as
unidades de polícia pacificadora vão pro
brejo gente campo branco
se você não colocar nessas desses
territórios da cidade
a possibilidade de você levar para lá o
estado de direito e um estado de direito
não é composto só por segurança e sim é
composto também por uma série de outros
fatores e benfeitorias sociais bem
feitorias de infraestrutura aí sim nós
vamos ter uma cidade integrada e não a
cidade partida que zuenir ventura 100
falou idéias tragam magritte aqui né e
idéias é que constrói o futuro idéias
serão sempre sempre bem vindas
só que talvez a principal ideia seja
entender que nós vivemos numa democracia
e numa democracia a ideia não é uma
coisa que nasce necessariamente de cima
para baixo
a ideia é necessário ouvir o pensamento
da população
nós temos parar com essa história do
estado tem que ficar tutelando a
sociedade a vida inteira
ao contrário a sociedade tem que
tutelava o estado
portanto criar novos paradigmas é
indispensável e eu acredito que será a
juventude a grande protagonista desse
processo para para terminar porque deu
00 aqui eu tenho que terminar a pena a
gente se empolga e começa a falar e não
para
mas eu acho que pensará a cidade do
século 21 tem que ser completamente
diferente do que se pensava se a cidade
do século 20
o momento no meu modo de ver é mais para
dúvidas do que para certezas vão parar
um pouco com essa arrogância da certeza
de que tudo tem resposta tecnologia
gráfica econômica e isso é balela o que
vale e termino com essa expressão que é
a expressão do escritor italiano italo
calvino que diz essa frase maravilhosa e
eu terminaria com ela dizendo de uma
cidade
nós não aproveitamos as suas sete os 77
maravilhas mas a resposta que dá às
nossas perguntas
obrigado